Hello. So, um, I'm Etiene Dalcol I'm a software engineering
student from Brazil, I'm currently studying
in France. And I also develop sailor, which
is a LUA MVC framework. Some months
ago I was invited to present add MLH at a
conference women's international leadership
at Bremen, besides presenting MLH and inviting
people to hack ton, I was supposed to five
a two hour workshop on programming. There
are a lot of things I would like to share
with you. Some of the topics I'll cover during
the talk is why using JavaScript instead of
some other language, that is visible in such
a short time, why inspiring people is important
and my personal growth from all of this. So
let's begin with the choice of JavaScript,
well, a language was not imposed on me, I
was just told to give an introduction workshop,
so I was free to chose what I wanted. The
story tis not again with JavaScript, it begins
with Lua, one week before the conference,
I participate in the a Hacathon where I built
a card game using Lua and a game development
framework called love 2 D, I was really improved
how fast and fun it was. You can see the look
on my face, seem to be having a lot of fun.
And I never did lots of game development,
but it actually remained me of my first programming
experience. There was this on‑line became
called Rag or rock on‑line, we could run
local servers, we could modify the game, I
remember exactly the first day where I got
my own character working and I could click
on it and it would do exactly what I thought
it should do. And it was magical, it was powerful?
AAnd I thought if I could relate to that,
maybe some other people would. So I said,
okay, I'll go with them through this game,
I had just made in Lua, but then there was
some problems, well, not really problems but
things that could get improved. I started
considering some other options. So, I had
two hours and I really just wanted to cover
some basics, variables, array, etc., and we
need to be really careful when picking a language
to teach a beginner, sometimes it's as if
we forget the basic structure of a language.
For example, I could go for a language just
because it has lots of libraries, lots of
tools, loathes of tutorials, specific for
beginners, for example Python, but I remember
my first Python, and I remember taking over
30 minutes to find out what was wrong with
my code when it looked exactly like the tutorial
I was following. I it looked equal but it
just didn't work. It was because, somewhere,
somewhere in the code there were four spaces
where there was supposed to be a tab, and
I started having home sigh deal thoughts.
So I said, um ... yeah, maybe, let's consider
some other options. So what about JavaScript?
I said, um ... maybe it's complex, right you
can do incredible stuff with script, I thought
we don't need the whole thing, we just need
a subset of the language, and the subset is
not scary at all to beginners, I said, okay,
JavaScript seems like a good choice. And another
point was I wouldn't be giving the workshop
alone, well 150 is a lot of people, so the
conference organizer, wound herbful team of
volunteers, they walk around‑‑ a wonderful
team of volunteers, they walk around and assist
and everything. They said it would be better
if we use a language that we all have in common.
Lua is great, but somewhat obscure, JavaScript
was the language we all knew. And there's
also the question about the tools needed.
So, setting up a development environment quickest
and nicest and most pleasant activities we
take before we starting to programming something.
And while Lua and the love 2D framework is
really super easy to get going, I'm saying
that from my perspective as a software engineering
student, I'm dealing with an audience that
consists of non‑tech participants. So the
thing to cowas to reduce the time to zero.
Everyone already has what it takes to code
JavaScript on their compute computer, everybody
has a browser. Not even just a browser, someone
on the team suggest wed use Mozilla Thimble,
we can see the code, use side by side (Mozilla)
it's really easy to use. So, to sum up, about
JavaScript has zero effort, it doesn't need
additional libraries or frameworks to make
graphics, which makes everything very easy
to remember in case they want to try it out
later. And it's also pretty useful in a beginners
context. mean, I'm sure the first program
will not be a TCP/IP protocol. And I know
they tonight want to know what Monads are.
So, JavaScript enables people to write games
and web sites, which is exactly the same kind
of software they have direct contact with
on a daily basis. So, okay, the plan said
I was going to port my game from Lua to JavaScript
and starting to plan the workshop. So let's
talk about the feasibility in two hours. This
is a part, very detailed oriented, every tiny
thing we can do to save time counts, so I
have some tips and tricks to share with you.
So, first, I recommend having everything ready.
Even if you're teaching something very simple,
I wouldn't suggest impro vising. Not because
you could make a mistake and make a fool of
yourself in front of everyone, if we're giving
a workshop, chances are you know more than
the audience, so you really tonight have to
worry about that but the thing is, if you
make a mistake you lose time, and if you has
time, you take away from the audience the
opportunity to learn something else that could
have been learning during that time. So having
that in mind, Skeleton code is very useful.
Whale it would be much more‑‑ while
you could teach much more by developing everything
from scratch, it is simply not feasible. So
what I did exactly was that I prepared the
whole game, then I removed some parts so I
could have them fill and modify. For example,
when I first explained what a variable is,
I would say, oh, hey hear's a variable called
scale, it's being used to multiply the width
and height of all um imagines in a game. If
you nodfy it, you can see the whole game shrink
or enlarge, when I first talk about functions
I could say, hey, let's make the function
that makes the duck move and so on. So every
tiny bit of the game was something I wanted
to teach. Now this is something that looks
really simple, but it's really useful compared
to the foreign text to get going. Having a
short easy pronounceable URL can save a whole
five ten mens of the participants being clueless
and asking each other what's going on, I really
suggest that if you have anything to download
or any materials to share. Also, give them
time to write their code, but be prepared
to say times up, give out the answer and move
on to the next topic. Because it's normal
if the participants get stuck in some aspect,
but you don't have to stop the workshop there
and wait until everyone's done, because some
students they might not come up with a good
answer by themselves, but they will understand
once you explain it. also suggest not moving
to the next topic without first giving the
answer to the last one, because you might
lose someone there, participants may get stuck
and trying to solve that little thing until
the end of the workshop and get out of there
really frustrated. And believe me, you don't
want people to get out of your workshop frustrated.
It can also happen that you don't have time
to show them everything you planned. So, I
really recommend leaving the extra things
for the end, so in my case, for example, I
was planning to teach them operators by making
the wings of the duck flap, and some flux
control by hitting the duck and killing it.
So, we need to think what is more important
in terms of programming and what makes more
sense in the whole context. So in the case
of my workshop I wanted the participants to
have a complete and playable became by the
end so that the‑‑ should die. I moved
the flapping to the end, because in the end
we rain out of time and it did have to be
cut off, so it was a good idea. And last thing,
before I move on to the next topic is typography.
I'm giving special attention to this pause
this is something
I messed up. I was reaching between the‑‑
switching between the slide and the code and
when I was explaining something using the
slides, like I said, I was presenting HML,
and they have a branded style for using the
style in the company, so I didn't give much
thought to it. So, this is for example, it
worked just fine. But when I said, hey, let's
make the function that makes the duck move,
then it didn't work at all. Can you guess
why? It was horrible for them to know what
exactly what paren that sis or brackets or
could recallly on my crappy slide and it confused
the hell out of them when I switched the code.
And the funny thing is that I did show the
slides to friends two are programmers, to
people on the team, to people from MLH, and
nobody has a flag there, because this is obvious
to us, we already know those are parenthesis
When it's not obvious to us, then it's really
irritating (parenthesis) and I got particularly
mad at myself because I'm often complaining
when professors do this, and then I went and
did the very same thing, so, yeah ... I'll
definitely take this as a lesson for the next
time, typography is really important. Okay,
so, we got to the end, we're able to do the
whole game during the workshop with moving
ducks that could be shot and killed. And to
me this is hugh. This is a hugh progress for
two hours, and we should be making this more
often. But given that teaching a practical
skill alone is not enough. Inspiring is important.
So I wanted to give them reasons to feel encouraged
so they could enjoy the technicality a bit
more and also get curious once the workshop
is over, so they can experiment with it later,
maybe start programming more. But how? How
do they go from one stage to the other? Well,
one way is to show them examples of things
they can build with technology. You can also
show them people having fun with things they
can build. Well, a particular aspect of my
workshop was that directed at young women
and I really wanted to show them that computer
science and programming is indeed a place
where women can be, which is something I am
constantly not convinced myself, so, we all
in this universe can with be a little challenging
to women. Please forgive my crappy drawing
abilities. That one is me, I'm really happy
to see such a diverse conference here, more
often than not, I am the only woman in the
room when I'm dealing with technology. And
I really wanted to show them that this is
not the case, that this does not represent
the reality as a whole. So, I really wanted
to show them role models, because it can be
really de‑motivating when we see only images
of successful males in our field. Because
if we don't see people like us doing these
things, we believe we can do these things
as well‑‑ we we believe we can't do
these things as well. As I was searching pictures
and stories to show them, I‑‑ that was
the first time I felt it was really important,
we had been discussing this often in our community,
and I'm really happy about it, but this is
when I felt it for real because when I was
looking for the source the show ‑‑ itches
really excited to show these womens to other
women, I am teaching programming and I'm not
going anywhere. This was a moment that I absolutely
needed to go through this list of amazing
women. And I'm not sure
and I'm not sure when I'll ever stop needing
that. So and I hope that this was as important
to the audience as it was for me. I hope some
of them were positively surprised to hear
some of those names for the first time, just
like I was when I first heard over them as
well. When I saw the room filled with women
programming, so excited about the ducks moving
for the first time, I did learn something
else. I mean lack at her, she's actually enjoying
it. And, I can't really express in words how
it was by the end of the workshop. There was
this woman that came to me and said, computers
hate me. Everything I touch crashes. I'm just
horrible with computers. But she managed to
get everything working and she was so happy,
and she was asking me for materials. So I
just gave her like code academy, and it was
amazing, other people were asking how to modify
the game into doing this or that. And it got
me like this ear to ear smile that I just
can't get off my face. And I learned that
teaching is so rewarding, this is the moment
I said, I must do this for life. This is amazing.
So if you forget like everything I've been
saying in this talk, please remember this:
Teach people. If you have any time to spare,
reserve some time to teach people. Especially
if it relates to something you care about.
Because it gathers this feeling we can do
this, we can totally do this. In two hours
we can do amazing things. And while people
are coming to thank me for the workshop I
was thanking them. So,‑‑ I was thanking
them, it was such an amazing feeling that
I want everyone else to feel the same thing.
I'm very happy to share all the materials
of my talk, of my workshop. If you go on my
GitHub Repository you'll find everything.
You'll find the full code, you'll find the
Skeleton code, you'll find the slides. I have
made a different version of the slides with
different typography. And so you can download
everything. I also have the old version for
people that work with MLH by any chance. So,
I'm finishing this really early. And I'm really
bad. This is the end of my talk, if you have
any questions, I'll be around, you can also
find me on Twitter. And that's it. thank you.
(Applause)